we begin tonight with a tragic shooting
in Thousand Oaks California and a
heartbreaking title Hollywood Kevin
Frazier's on the scene at the family
reunification Center ladies it is
gut-wrenching being here at the Teen
Center in Thousand Oaks where families
are being notified about their loved
ones now Adam Housley as a correspondent
for Fox News was one of the first on the
scene during the Las Vegas shooting
today he and his wife Tamera Mowry
Housley find themselves on the other
side of the tragedy how will you
celebrate her life Stan you know she
helped people she was always there and
she volunteered to coach soccer she was
just a good human being just minutes
earlier Adam and his wife actress Tamera
Mowry co-host of the reel confirmed the
heartbreaking news about their niece
quote we are devastated that her life
was cut short in this manner
Elena Housley was with a group of
friends for college night at the
borderline Bar and Grille
when suspected gunman Ian David long
opened fire Adam told reporters that
Elena's Apple watch and iPhone still
showed her location on the dance floor
you were standing out in front of the
bar trying to call her correct yeah
what'd you do she's mine she's my
goddaughter
you know that's Elena at Adam and
Tamara's wedding in 2011 after news of
the horrible shooting broke the couple
spent the morning holding on to hope
Adam asked his social media followers
for support and wrote staying positive
and praying and hoping and wishing there
was more I could do he was an incredible
beautiful girl who didn't hurt anybody
and was excited to go to Italy for the
program overseas and senseless man
now Adams six-year-old son told his wife
is she grieved the loss of her niece
that don't worry she'll be back as a
beautiful baby
[Music]